Morgen lieben. Guten Morgen Tim.
Tja, wer hätte gedacht, dass die SPD sich nochmal an die Macht umfällt.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik Nummer zweihundertsiebenunddreißig frisch auf den Tisch am sechzehnten Dezember zwanzig siebzehn und das ist dann aber auch wirklich die letzte Sendung in diesem Jahr.
Ja, also wir haben ja schon in Schwierigkeiten gehabt, diese hier noch zu terminieren, der vierunddreißig C drei zerrt an der Zeit.
Und.
Nur der.
Beim Kongress werden wir keine Sendung machen. Also das ist die, das ist jetzt einfach der Jahresabschluss.
Müssen damit klarkommen.
Ja äh geht halt einfach anders nicht.
So ist das. Immer wieder trotz aller Planerei und so äh ist so ein Kongress halt dann doch irgendwie etwas, was Zeit, also was äh Zeit, Zeit, Zeit.
Stimmt, guckt auf die Uhr. Also, komm, wir müssen lieber das Thema nächstes Thema.
Äh wir haben Feedback bekommen zur letzten Sendung, unglaublich viel Feedback. Ähm.
Ja. Vor allem wurden wir erstmal wieder korrigiert. Zurecht.
Zurecht korrigiert, wobei ich also sagen muss, wir sind auch Menschen und wir haben auch Gefühle.
Echt?
Ich wollte nur nochmal dran erinnern.
Dachte, wir sind so anerkannte Podcast-Roboter, die alles raushauen ohne größere Anstrengungen.
Kann man's ja machen. Ähm.
Wir haben uns äh zu dem Thema Bilderkennung bei Facebook sehr eindeutig verrannt. Das war äh in den in den Shownotes, als wir machen mal einen kleinen Witz und dann sind wir da in diese AI-Nummer abgestiegen.
Also ich vor allem.
Ja oder da haben wir dann auch zu gesagt bekommen Freunde, erstens wichtige Kultur, das war mir auch nicht so ganz klar, Gott konnte ich mich mal einlesen wie das ist ein Imagehashing-Algorithmus gibt,
Namens Foto-DNA von Microsoft ursprünglich entwickelt. Ähm der.
Folgendermaßen funktioniert, wir haben ja gesagt, wenn man nur ein Bit an dem Bild ändert, dann äh fallen fangen äh schlagen
klassische Hashing-Algorithmen an und machen ein anderes Bild, äh machen eine andere Prüfsumme und dieses Foto-DNA geht im Prinzip hin und zerzieht den Kon
Trast des Bildes hoch.
Macht dadurch also quasi eine Kantendetektion, also wo sind Übergänge zwischen Farben und schneidet das Bild dann auf in gleich in in unterschiedliche Vierecke und macht jeweils ein,
Ein Hash über die hochauflösende über die über eine niedrig auflösenderen Verlauf dieser Kanten. In ganz vielen Teilen des Bildes. Das heißt, du machst äh du du ziehst das Bild halt quasi in seine Essenz runter,
durch den Kontrast, das was der Mensch wirklich an Kanten wahrnimmt und über das, was du dann noch in in niedrigerer Auflösung hast, machst du quasi eine Prüfsumme und davon machst du mehrere Probild,
Weil du ja ganz viele Viereckige hast und dann machst du das quasi über den über ein Video, halt über jedes Einzelbild dieses Videos. Und wenn dann da irgendwas an dem Bild verändert wird, dann hast du eben eine hohe Chance, dass du,
trotzdem noch sehr ähnliche Wege. Also das es trotzdem wiedererkennst. Genauso wie ein menschliches Gehirn eben trotzdem.
Ähnlichkeiten feststellt, weil weil nicht jede nicht jedes Planquadrat äh trifft dann der Hashtag zu, aber so und so viele, so ein gewisser Freshhold.
Du kannst halt einen Frechheit definieren, wo du sagst, das ist komm, Freunde, das ist einfach das Gleiche nochmal.
Und wenn da jetzt diese ganzen klassischen äh Umgehungsversuche, wie ich mache, einen roten Rahmen drum oder sowas, das würdest du halt alles erkennen, ne?
Und ähm also das ist hier der der Ansatz grob äh gesagt. Und es gibt solche Sachen, gibt's sogar auch ähm,
Open Source ähnliche Sachen, ja? Also das ist der erste Punkt, warum wir überhaupt gar keine gar keine AI oder sonstiges für.
Ja, zumal ja Ei Methodiken, also Maschinen Learning immer äh da beim richtigen Begriff gleich zu bleiben. Halt äh
damit arbeitet, dass man im Prinzip vorher halt viele Wahrheiten sammelt, die trainiert und dann eben Software erzeugt, die quasi diese sich dort äh diese diese vorbereiteten Wahrheiten dann eben abprüft mit neuem Material, aber das taugt eben nicht zur Erkennung von
dem gleichen so, ne?
Also klassischer Anwendungsfall, Maschine Learning ist, wer bei Facebook eben wir wollen keine weiblichen Nippel, hier sind hier ist eine Lernmaterial, weibliche Nippel, ab jetzt erkenne jeden weiblichen Nippel. Ja, das heißt.
Genau. Schön, schön trennen von den männlichen Lippen, weil die sind ja erlaubt. Die sind erlaubt. Ja. Weil männliche Nippel sind ja nicht so schlimm.
Die sind erlaubt. So, ich finde männlich ehrlich gesagt schlimmer, aber.
Ich finde, ich sage schlimmer. Ja, ich auch.
So jetzt kommt er. Äh jetzt kommt der ähm.
Das heißt hier wirklich ein Hashing-Algorithmus und nix, nix, wo man ins für zukünftige Bewertungen lernen soll, sondern hier sollen ja einzelne Materialien spezifisch
gesperrt werden. Also alles was wir da was wir da noch über Macht Learning dazu gesagt haben ist eher nicht,
nicht dem Thema äh entsprechend. Dann aber.
Und zwei Fakten bleiben, nur damit ihr nicht sagt, äh alles was wir gesagt haben ist falsch, denn äh Bilder zu Facebook hochladen ist trotzdem keine gute Idee und es ist auch äh es bleibt trotzdem auch unser Fazit, dass Facebook gleichzeitig nicht,
Ergebnisse von die ihr selber generiert habt,
akzeptieren kann. Sowas mag Facebook nur bei vertrauenswürdigen Leuten, wie zum Beispiel der Content Mafia, die wo sie sich eigentlich quasi,
ohne den Inhalt überhaupt zu kennen, sagen lassen, okay, alles klar, das könnt ihr sperren und ihr könnt hier Takedown und hast alles nicht gesehen machen. Also es bleibt eine eine verrückte.
Idee, äh Marabu äh kommentierte dazu, ich halte es nicht für sinnvoll, pornografische Aufnahmen proaktiv weiterzugeben. Wenn diese Bilder nie veröffentlicht wurden, aber wenn diese Bloßstellung bereits geschah, dann kann ich dem auch einen Nutzen abgewinnen.
Genau in diesem Zusammenhang kommen diese Techniken eben auch seit hier zum Einsatz, denn dieses Foto DNR hat Microsoft unter anderem diesen White-IT-Leuten gespendet, die,
um Foto-DNA zur Anwendung kommen zu lassen, um äh dokumentierten Kindesmissbrauch und ähnliche äh Materialien
direkt proaktiv zu löschen. Wenn sie eben einmal bekannt sind? Hm ja, so viel zu dem Thema.
Ich halte es nach wie vor für eine völlig blöde Idee, Sachen bei Facebook hochzuladen. Eigentlich sogar egal was. Würde ich, also ich könnte eigentlich so, was würde ich, was ist sinnvoll bei Facebook hochzuladen? Hm.
Jetzt will Facebook auch noch irgendwie, dass man sich mit seiner eigenen Fresse äh Captures freischaltet.
Das ist wiederum, da muss ich mal sagen, das ist echt eine gar nicht so also.
Ich finde ja, es gibt ja immer zwei Aspekte. Es ist gar nicht so eine blöde Idee.
Als Capture zu sagen, zeig mir ein Foto von einem Menschen. Und zwar in diesem Moment. Und das Kriterium, was Facebook dazu an zur Anwendung bringt, ist natürlich das Bild,
Gab zu keinem Zeitpunkt irgendwo anders. Also das ist wieder die krasse Macht, die dahinter steckt, ne. Normalerweise würdest du sagen,
Das Skeptire-Ding will ein Selfie haben, alles klar, Google, Imagesuche, Selfie, äh Suchergebnisse vierundfünfzig, das Bild lade ich jetzt Facebook hoch, aber Facebook kennt ja das Internet und sagt, äh,
der Selfie kenne ich. Das ist von mir mein Freund. Jetzt habe ich hier in meiner Datenbank. Ähm insofern eine.
Technologisch natürlich irgendwie echt eine crazy Idee.
Und irgendwie auch eine auf eine Weise, eine faszinierende Lösung für ein Problem, aber natürlich auch eine der äh der Schreckenszenarien am Horizont, ja.
Warum muss es denn unbedingt ein Gesicht sein, was man in dem Moment macht? Ich meine, wenn.
Nee, ich meine, wenn's nur darum geht, ein Foto, was es sozusagen sonst nicht gibt, dann kann ja auch wie mein Regal äh Fotograf.
Na ja, natürlich, weil er, weil Facebook gucken wird, dass es auch jedes Mal der gleiche Mensch ist.
Also einfach nur, ne? Halt, ich die kenne dich ja schon seit Jahren,
Also die die lassen sich doch schon seit Jahren in allen möglichen Bildern taggen. Die wissen doch wie du aussiehst. Und jetzt ist einfach so, bist du Beweise, dass du du bist, indem du mir unter Beweis stellst, dass du spontan in der Lage bist, ein Bild von dir zu produzieren.
Nix anderes macht das iPhone. Äh X.
Na ja, doch. Erstmal macht es kein Foto von dir und zweitens äh lädt es das nicht hoch.
Sagte er.
Sagt Apple, Apple, sagt immer die Wahrheit.
Nein, also natürlich ist hier der der.
Also der der also der Punkt ist, Facebook ist quasi durch die durch den Zugriff auf Bilddaten, die sie haben.
Mit ausreichend guter Wahrscheinlichkeit in der Lage festzustellen, ob es ein Foto schon mal irgendwo gab.
Was erschreckend genug ist? Das ist das Erschreckende daran. Andererseits sind sie daran inzwischen so gut, dass sie offenbar sagen.
Wir können's mit der Idee aufnehmen, also Apple macht's lokal und sagt, okay, wir haben diesen Infrarotsensor äh um festzustellen, dass das, was vor uns ist, mindestens eine 3D-Puppe ist. Ähm wir haben,
Ein wir haben unglaubliche Kenntnisse über die Biometrie dieses Gesicht, also die hat Facebook aber auch. Das, was Apple mit Face ID macht, lokal ist ja eigentlich nur Fälschungserkennung,
Das ist der, also wenn du sowas machst, ist die das, was du eigentlich machen musst, ist Fälschungserkennung, das ist dein dein technisches Problem.
Und einfach sicherstellen, dass nix falsches vorgehalten wird,
Und Facebook kann sagt einfach, na ja okay, äh Fälschungserkennung machen wir über alle Bilder, die es gibt, kennen wir eh. Das heißt,
Wir gehen zumindest schon mal davon aus, dass kein falsches Bild hochgeladen wird. Das heißt, unsere Falls positiv Wahrscheinlichkeit haben wir eingegrenzt auf jemand hat,
Bild von dir gemacht zu einem anderen Zeitpunkt und das für den Authentisierungsfall zurückgehalten.
Und.
Auf, na ja, wir sind, was weiß ich, die die klassischen Fehler, die wir haben. Es ist auf jeden Fall technologisch faszinierend ähm und damit natürlich auch, wenn es Facebook kann, erschreckend, dass sie das gut genug können, dass sie sagen, das reicht uns als ein zweiter Faktor.
Und davor meinen sie ja dann, dass sie das Bild prüfen und es dann permanent wiederum löschen?
Ja, wahrscheinlich machen sie halt ein Foto DNA äh Ding davon. Also sie werden natürlich nicht das permanent löschen. Wenn du das gleiche Bild beim zweiten Mal nochmal hochlätzt, wenn sie sagen, das hast du schon hochgeladen. Selbstverständlich äh ähm.
Gott.
Also das ist crazy, dass die dass wenn man sich überlegt, was du.
Was Facebook damit unter Beweis stellt an, wie viel Bilder sie haben und über wie viel.
Fähigkeiten, sie verfügen das auch aus.
Sie da verhaar äh da haben, dieses Verfahren anzubieten und dabei zu sagen, das ist offenbar ausreichend gut, beziehungsweise so wie ich diesen Artikel lese, sind sie noch in einer Probephase und sie werden im Zweifelsfall positiv abschließen,
Das ist schon relativ beängstigend,
dass sie dass dass sie das ausreichend gut können um zu sagen da machen wir sogar einen zweiten Faktor in der Authentifizierung raus.
Ja, der Artikel hier bei,
stellt er dann auch nochmal Bezug zu dem aktuellen Problem mit den ganzen gefälschten Identitäten und dem Russlandscam, der in USA abgelaufen ist auf Facebook und Twitter,
Oh man ey, das ist wirklich die Büchse der Pandora, diese ganzen Social äh Networks, ne? Hätten jetzt auch schon alte Facebo
äh Heroden und äh Investoren und Camera sind und sagen irgendwie, das ist alles ganz äh furchtbar, wie sich das entwickelt hat und wir müssen jetzt davor warnen.
Wer hätte uns nur früher jemand gewarnt.
Ja, hatte nur irgendjemand gesagt, dass es keine gute Idee ist. Tja.
Okay, aber ähm das ist eigentlich, wir sind nur noch bei Feedback, deswegen gehen wir oder Nachlese, Nachle.
Ich muss irgendwann mal ich versinke in mir so ein wenig, weil ich ähm meinen Berufsoptimismus ja mal so einer Chaosradiosendung auch zur Schau gestellt habe. Äh.
Inzwischen gelöscht.
Nee, das nicht, aber äh ich hab's ja auch ehrlich gesagt, müsste ich's mir immer nochmal anhören. Äh vielleicht mal.
Soziale Netzwerke oder.
Twitter-Demokratie habe ich das genannt und das war alles noch so ein bisschen mit meinem,
Na ja, das war halt äh eine andere Zeit, ne? So äh rabischer Frühling, Pipapo, so die äh geblendeten Massen äh äh finden sich jetzt irgendwie über die Netze zusammen und äh alles wird gut.
Die geblendeten Masse, die erleuchteten Massen.
Na ja das vielleicht. Keine Ahnung. Ich muss mir die Sendung selber nochmal anhören, äh ob ich da nur Unfug erzählt habe oder.
Noch ein bisschen Ausreden habe. Man lernt.
Okay, dann hatten wir jetzt noch ganz kurz äh Nachlese zu diesem Überhack. Wir haben da ja gesagt, Uber wurde gehackt, hat irgendwie siebenundfünfzig Millionen Nutzerdaten verloren. Da hatten über sechshunderttausend Fahrer und haben ähm hunderttausend Euro bezahlt
für die Zusicherung, dass diese Daten ähm gelöscht werden.
Haben aber nicht irgendwie gesagt, wie sie dieser Person das Geld bezahlt haben, stellt sich raus ähm.
Uber hat diesen Menschen gesagt, ey pass auf, melde dich mal bei Hacker One, da haben wir einen Backbounty-Programm und dann kriegst, dann bezahlen wir dich über dieses Backbounty Programm.
Also zur Erklärung Backbounty ist, wenn äh Firma quasi Preise dafür auslobt, dass man äh Fehler in ihrer Software äh findet und dann da eben dafür Geld bezahlt, damit eben Leute eine ähm eine,
Motivation haben, äh, es eben direkt zu melden, an das Unternehmen, was davon betroffen ist, versus auf einem Schwarzmarkt zu verkaufen an Shady,
People. So und jetzt haben sie aber sozusagen Shady People quasi hinten rum wieder in ihr Legalisierungsmodell eingeschleust,
Tja, was sagt uns das.
Interessant, also Hacker One müsste sich da äh schon gut äh von distanzieren. Also dafür sind natürlich nicht gedacht, ne,
Andererseits ähm da bin ich mal gespannt, denn soweit habe ich dem jetzt auch nicht hinterher recherchiert, weil was mal spannend wäre, ist über Hacker One kann's natürlich nicht mal äh anonym zahlen. Das heißt, wir ähm es,
dieser Typ musste gegenüber Hacker One und Uwe natürlich auch sagen, wer er ist. Und ähm mich würde jetzt mal interessieren.
Da Uber jetzt natürlich Ärger kriegt wegen dieser.
Sehr in Bitcoin bezahlt.
Ja. Nee, der, der wurde nicht in Bitcoin bezahlt. Na ja. Aber das nur, dass wir darüber, das ist natürlich da, dass es nicht jetzt der Anwendungszweck von von Backbound Teeprogrammen.
Aber Hacker One ist jetzt nicht von Uber oder so, ne.
Nee, nee, also es gibt Hacker One und Backcroud, das sind so die beiden größeren, bekannteren ähm Backbountybuden, die das für dich anbieten,
wo du dich als Unternehmen anmelden kannst und die machen quasi auch so eine Art also man könnte sagen die machen wie nennt man das,
So Treuhänder schafft auch dafür. Ja, also du lobst halt was aus und sagst, pass auf, wir geben Backbound, die so und so für
oder oder wir nehmen hierüber Hinweise entgegen und dann
meldet dir jemand was und dann wird halt darüber entschieden, ob dieser Buck Elegable ist oder nicht und welchen Betrag du dafür bekommst. Und darum kümmert sich halt Hacker One, einer oder Backcroud eben, dadurch, dass Leute da gemeldet sind, dann kannst du halt einfach,
quasi als als Pantester, der gerade nichts zu tun hat,
Pentest, pentestet so dann irgendwie so ein bisschen rum, findest irgendwas, dann kannst du bei Hacker One direkt sagen. Und du kannst auch sagen, einfach machen wir denn heute mal.
Und guckst, wer gibt gerade am meisten, äh wer gibt gerade am meisten Geld raus? Und dann weißt du, wo du da deine Ressourcen,
verschwendest, äh, oder investierst. Und dann sind dann stellst du halt gibt's dann auch, dann sagen Sie am Ende OK der und der hier ist hat über uns so und so viel Geld verdient. Es gibt halt Menschen, die,
Im Prinzip darüber ihr Geld verdienen, dass sie einfach bei bei Backroad oder Hacker One,
Gucken, was ist wo interessante Sachen ausgelobt sind und das einstreichen und die damit halt irgendwie viel verdienen.
Einfach so eine ja.
Neben dir halt diesen, diesen Hassel ab, einerseits den Unternehmen. Also wenn du so ein Backpoint Programm anbietest, muss natürlich auch Leute haben, die sich ernsthaft darum kümmern, muss das alles einrichten und so. Während du halt bei Hacker One oder bei denen halt eine einfache Möglichkeit kriegst, die beraten dich natürlich auch dafür, nehmen natürlich auch ihren Teil dafür
aber das ist ja kann man jetzt.
Man kann an jedem Geschäftsmodell irgendwie was auszusetzen, finden und das ist,
natürlich auch wieder so ein wir sind an einer, wir sind an einem Kontaktpunkt und kassieren da ab, denen es eigentlich nicht
geben müsste, aber äh wir haben halt eine Community, einen ordentlichen Pantestern, wir zahlen gut, wir gelten als Unabhängige, äh, wir sorgen dafür, dass jetzt hier in in geordneten Bahnen verläuft und ähm dadurch natürlich auch,
dann ein Punkt zu unternehmen zu gehen und zu sagen, ey, meldet euch doch bei uns an.
Bei uns sind die guten Leute und dann lobt ihr da mal was aus und dann so, ne? Das ist halt dieses Ding.
Ja, also äh Herrn ist wohl nicht so begeistert davon und.
Nee, natürlich nicht.
Auch davon, dass wir irgendwie hunderttausend Dollar wäre auch ein Oldtimer-Record, also so viel wird da normalerweise nicht ausgezahlt, das ist eher so ein Bereich von fünf bis zehntausend Dollar und es handelt sich hier wohl um zwanzigjährigen aus Florida, der da irgendwie.
Ja, der machen Verhältnissen kommt und na ja, das Blöde, das Doofe ist halt der gute Mann ist dadurch natürlich auch in der Falle, äh dass er jetzt bekannt ist, also ich weiß nicht, ob diese Uwe Leute hier nicht am Ende noch äh,
dafür platt machen.
Wäre, würde mich nicht wundern. Ich meine, das sind halt die sind nicht dafür bekannt, äh besonders fair zu verfahren. Okay.
Viel Feedback und Nachlese haben wir zum zu der Aktion des Zentrums zur politischen Schönheit.
Wir erinnern uns, die eine populäres Denkmal nachgebaut haben.
Ein populäres Denkmal nachgebaut haben, was seitdem geschah. Also erstens haben sie ein, also,
mit sehr mit sehr viel Interesse konnte man ja äh feststellen wie sich alle über diese,
Überwachung aufgeregt haben, ja? Also was erlaube, Zentrum für politische Schönheit, einfach jemanden zu überwachen,
Wir kämpfen einerseits gegen Geheimdienste und wenn das aber jetzt auf einmal gegen gegen gegen Rechte geht, gegen Leute, die wir politisch nicht akzeptabel finden, da finden wir es auf einmal total gut.
Na ja, also da ist natürlich der Vergleich äh schmeichelt natürlich enorm
dem Zentrum für politische Schönheit, wenn seine Überwachungskapazitäten mit denen des Bundesamtes für Verfassungsschutz oder des äh des BND gleichgesetzt werden. Das ist der erste Punkt. Zweitens,
habe ich glaube ich.
Nur in meinen kühnsten Tagen die These vertreten, dass man auf diese Geheimdienste vollständig verzichten sollte. Ähm ich denke,
Es ist relativ klar, dass wir ähm gegen bestimmte Bemühungen, Bestrebungen verschiedener verfassungsfeindlicher Gruppen in diesem Land,
auch ein Inlandsgeheimdienst brauchen und dass wir gegen die Bemühungen ähm verschiedener äh Deutschland, Menschen und Demokratie feindlicher äh Gruppen auch ein Auslandsgeheimdienst brauchen
Ähm das heißt nicht, dass wir den auch zum Schutz unserer wirtschaftlichen Interessen brauchen, das war heißt nicht, dass wir ein Inlandsgeheimnis zu Maßen Überwachung.
Ähm aller Bürger brauchen,
wo gegen wir uns richten, ist erstens wenig Kontroll, wenig bis keine Kontrolle der Geheimdienste, zweitens Massenüberwachung. Drittens, Nutzung dieser Überwachungsergebnisse in äh,
in Zweckfremden äh Szenarien, also insbesondere was weiß ich, Wirtschaftsförderung, Wirtschaftsspionage und sonstiges. Ähm.
Wir brauchen auch vor allem keine Geheimdienste, um äh Rechtsradikale
Aktivisten in Don und Brot zu bringen als Frau Männer zu installieren und dann im Zweifelsfall halt auch noch diese ganzen Aktivitäten nach nachweislich zu vertuschen, äh Belegeunterlagen dazu zu vernichten et cetera an sich generell
dort keine Arechenschaft äh zu stellen.
Also so in ihrer jetzigen Form sind wir uns glaube ich einig, Schadengeheimdienste mehr, als dass sie nutzen,
Das heißt nicht direkt, dass die gesamte Idee der Geheimdienste unbedingt vollständig ähm äh aufgelöst gehört,
Aber ich sage mal, der Geheimdienst, mit dem ich zufrieden wäre, wäre auf jeden Fall ein ganz anderer,
und würde auch ganz anderen Maßgaben und Regeln und Kontrollmöglichkeiten unterlegen,
ja? Ähm so viel mehr zu der Idee des Geheimnisses. Insofern interessant, dass sich über die Massenüberwachung, über die Edward Snowden Sachen heute kein,
Mensch mehr aufrecht, da kriegst du keinen mehr äh zu zu motiviert, insbesondere auch hier. Konstanze hat das ja auch angesprochen, äh mit dem Hörbuch, dass sie,
dass sie mit vielen Freiwilligen über ihre Artikel von und die von Frank Rieger hat bauen lassen über vier Jahre,
sich auch die Art ändert, wie man über Themen schreibt, ja? Das werden sie Massenüberwachung der sozialen Netzwerke inzwischen völlig okay, finden sich da niemand mehr drüber echraffiert. Aber wenn jemand dem Höcke was in den Garten baut und eine Salatschüssel äh auf ihn richtet,
und ein paar Ausschnitte vom ZDF nutzt und sagt, ho, ho, ho, wir haben den jetzt überwacht, dann ist der Aufschrei auf einmal riesengroß. Ja, das ist äh das würde sehr schön äh beobachtet auch von.
Markus Reuter, der da einen Artikel auf Netzpolitik Orgisch zugeschrieben hat, unter der endlich Reden Leute über Überwachung. Ähm dann,
Natürlich wir haben ja
dass im letzten Logbuch noch sehr vorsichtig angedeutet, dass man gucken müsste, was bei diesem Überwachungsthema noch so kommt und dass wir natürlich auch nicht alle Methoden da gut heißen und dass wir natürlich die Privatsphäre von Personen gerne geschützt werden wissen mögen,
und wir können feststellen, das Zentrum für politische Schönheit hat da keine Privatsphäreverletzung. Ähm.
Vorgenommen. Ganz im Gegenteil haben sie dann einige Tage später einen YouTube-Video veröffentlicht, in dem sie mal zeigen, wie in diesem Video diese Überwachungsmöglichkeiten äh.
Dargestellt wurden, also wo sie dann irgendwie Höcke beim Spazieren, das waren irgendwelche Ausschnitte aus äh aus irgendeiner ZDF-Doku. Ja, die haben diese irgendwie was von YouTube runtergeladen,
und irgendwie Höcke im Hotelzimmer war auch irgendeine Aufnahme von irgendwem
die sie halt dann mit dem Filter versehen haben und außerdem ihr wie gesagt ihr Abhörequipment was sie da hatten diese
Pistole, die irgendwie so ein Richtmikrofon nachbauen sollte, weil irgendwie eine Salatschüssel und die Trenchcodes, die sie da anhatten, äh die hatten sie im Winter vorher von Penny,
Also.
Das haben sie so schön im äh.
Das haben sie so schön im äh im Sendung mit der Maus.
Ton äh wiedergegeben, wobei ich sagen muss, das haben sie von Starbuck und mir geklaut. Nein, das haben sie natürlich von der Sendung mit der Maus geklaut. Okay.
Interessant ist auch, was dann da noch so los war in Bornhagen, ne? Gibt's dann schöne äh Dokus ähm.
Wo, wo sie wo ähm wo die Leute, wo die quasi jetzt in ihr Gebäude wollten, also das Haus ist, das haben sie ja nun mal gemietet und dann war da die Bornhagener Bürgerwehr, ja und hat sich gegen das Gesidel gestellt,
Gegen das Bolschewistenpack,
Und hat die irgendwie mitunter Einsatz von Körperlichkeit daran gehindert, ihr eigenes Haus zu gehen. Wir hatten irgendwie diesen AfD-Abgeordneten, der ist ja völlig drüber. Also wie heißt dieser Typ nochmal? Mal kurz gucken. Ähm.
Welchen Mindset.
Na ja, der äh mit der Machete, der offenbar abends besoffen zu Hause saß, mit der Machete und gesagt hat, er wartet auf das Zentrum für politische Schönheit. Ist das nicht gesehen.
Hast du nicht gesehen? Das habe ich nicht mitbekommen.
Der hat ähm wer war das denn? Mein, also ich habe mir diese diese neuen, diese neue Freakshow da noch nicht irgendwie alle mit Namen gemerkt. Ähm.
Warte mal. Der hat.
Google mal irgendwie kurz Machete, dann willst du das finden. Hier ist er. Stefan Brandner, Mitglied des Deutschen Bundestages, am neunten Dezember, ne? Fotografiert sein Bier, was er da säuft und eine Machete.
Und twittert dazu, warten auf die Antifa oder der, die das Zentrum für politische Schönheit, ZPS, das sind die bekloppten Kunstbollos, die in Bornhagen rumirren. Vielleicht können die,
Können dieen einen Tipp geben, wie ich das Gerät künstlerisch gebrauchen kann? Ähm mit irgendwie allerlei Hashtags. So, da sitzt halt irgendwie so ein einsamer Irrer.
Mit einer Waffe und besäuft sich und.
Kombination.
Also ich meine, kannst du ja auch, ja, die Leute habt ihr gewählt, Freunde. Äh aber Linus Linus hat immer nur Theater gemacht. Schön ist, diese Mareta hat aber genau die Form des AfD-Hakens. Äh den die AfD.
Wo äh das wurde dann natürlich auch direkt nochmal verwertet. Alternative für Deutschland mit der Machete drunter.
Von Kommissar Keller. Sehr schön. Auch diesen Tweet müssen wir unbedingt noch verlinken.
Ist das eigentlich eine Machete wirklich.
Was? Ich kenne mich jetzt nicht so aus. Soweit ist das denn? Ja, so ein Machete oder nicht.
Weiß nicht, sieht so ein bisschen arabisch aus.
Sieht so ein bisschen arabisch angehauert aus, ne.
Was mehr sowas von arabischen Deutsch, als von der Machete.
So Ali oh oh oh meinst du meinst du das ist so 'ne so 'n Islamistenschwert oder was.
Also bin da nicht wirklich.
Also abendländisch sieht das auf jeden Fall nicht aus.
Das würde ich auf jeden Fall auch sagen.
Ähm dann wurde der Mietvertrag gekündigt.
Auch interessant. Ähm bin ich mal gespannt, wie das noch weitergeht. Ja, wenn du, wenn du irgendwie, ja, stimmt, wenn du Machete scheint, das nicht zu sein. Also der, der Vermieter hat jetzt den Bewohnern des Hauses den Mietvertrag gekündigt.
Ähm.
Mhm. Was war die aber die Kündigungsfrist war doch irgendwie schon durch am Anfang. Außergewöhnliche Gründe oder was.
Na ja, keine Ahnung, wenn jemand, wenn jemand hier außergewöhnliche Gründe oder so, ja, es wird net, also ich gehe davon aus, dass das auch vor Gericht gehen wird. Ähm.
Dann Philipp Ruch darf nicht mehr in dieses Haus,
weil das die Höckes vor einem Thüringer Gericht durchgestritten haben, dass er irgendwie der Frau und Kinder Höcke sich nicht mehr auf fünfhundert Metern nähern darf und der Tausend ist ja fünfhundert Meter näher dran.
Ist auch geil, da hast du halt, dass du eine Gesetzgebung gegen gegen Stalker und äh und gewalttätige Irre, die Frauen oder Menschen verfolgen, ja? Äh.
Gegen gegen die du diese Schutzgesetzgebung hast und dann die ersten, die sind halt natürlich missbrauchen.
Sind natürlich solche sind die dann, ne? Haben halt jetzt quasi durchgesetzt, dass der Philip Ruch nicht mehr in das Haus darf, dessen legitimer Mieter ist, wo er wohnt,
Auch das wird natürlich nochmal vor Gericht landen,
Über all das, ich fasse das jetzt hier kurz nur in einer Nachlese zusammen, denn wir werden darüber in einem Vortrag beim vierunddreißig C drei natürlich noch viele Details hören. Ähm,
Zwei Aktionen, die noch weiter gegangen sind, das Zentrum für politische Schönheit hat,
DNA-Material von Björn Höcke, einem DNA-Test unterzogen und hat festgestellt, dass er eigentlich nur ein ausgewanderter Portugiese ist. Das heißt, sie haben jetzt A gezweifelt, ob er wirklich ein Blutdeutscher ist.
Aber warum, warum sie denn dieses DNA-Material her? Also ich meine, lässt sich das belegen, dass es auch wirklich seins ist.
Das werden wir vielleicht erfahren, vielleicht auch nie erfahren. Ich meine, das ist immer äh ich glaube langsam,
langsam erkennt man da ja das Muster bei der bei dem Zettel für politische Schönheit. Ähm und dann haben sie einen einen wunderschönen Onlineshop.
Äh unter Landolf Minus Ladig Punkt DE eingerichtet.
So, dazu muss man sagen, Landolf Ladig ist ein ein Kolumnist,
oder so ein regelmäßiger Autor in so einer NPD Zeitschrift so, also das halt so ein also bei der NPD ist man sich ja einig, dass das jetzt nicht,
dass das jetzt nicht irgendwie die neuen Konservativen sind oder so, sondern das sind halt dann doch eher Nationalisten und zwar irgendwie an der weit jenseits der Grenze des guten Geschmacks, während die AfD ja immer noch versucht damit zu kokettieren irgendwie nicht
äh nicht voll Nazi zu sein, ja? Äh was man ja dann auch merkt, wenn man sich zur AfD äußert und ihre Sympathisanten äh darauf dazu Stellung bezieht,
Landolf Ladig, also ein Pseudonym unter dem in dieser NPD Zeitschrift äh dann doch sehr klar, sehr klare Texte formuliert wurden und ähm,
eine ein es gibt im Prinzip nur noch wenig Zweifel daran, dass Landolf Ladig ein Pseudonym von Björn Höcke ist.
Und hier hat das Zentrum für politische Schönheit übrigens ein äh diesen Onlineshop angestellt mit so einem NPD Wahlplakat Landolf Ladig für Deutschland für Thüringen, für das Vaterland und äh ne für Thüringen, für das Volk, für Deutschland. Ähm,
Und verkaufen da irgendwie Tassen T-Shirts, Leggings, iPhone, Schoner und alles Mögliche mit so einem äh Hökomotiv.
Haben diese äh dieses Höckemotiv eben auch in Bornhagen an einigen äh an einigen Stellen als als Wahlplakate aufgestellt und.
Man es besteht also Anlass zu der Vermutung, dass das der Vollzug der Drohung ist, wenn wir veröffentlichen ist, äh Höckes politische Karriere am Ende,
Nun bisher ist das nicht erreicht, ja? Das das Karriereende ganz im Gegenteil äh bei dem letzten AfD-Parteitag oder was weiß er der, der rechtsnationale Flügel der AfD sehr stark gestärkt aus der Nummer ähm.
Hervorgegangen.
So viel erstmal weiter vom Zentrum für politische Schönheit beim vierunddreißig C drei äh geben wir dem Zentrum die Möglichkeit mal einen Blick hinter die Kulissen zu bieten, die Aktionen zu erzählen und na ja äh wahrscheinlich auch,
Leuten, die sich darüber echauffiert haben,
dann im Anschluss die Gelegenheit sich mit dem Zentrum darüber auseinanderzusetzen. Ähm, es ist auf jeden Fall mir so viel erlauben,
Es gibt auf jeden Fall echt größere Schwierigkeiten in unserer Zeit, als das, was das Zentrum für politische Schönheit hier gemacht hat. Was nicht, was nach wie vor nicht heißen soll, dass ich alles, was sie gemacht haben, uneingeschränkt. Gute Heiße.
Aber ich bin dann doch erstaunt.
Ähm welche Art der Kritik,
Und mit welcher Vehemenz sich ausgerechnet an dieser Kritik stellen müssen von Leuten, die sonst durch wenig Aktion oder,
Sonstiges auffallen. Das ist schon einfach immer auch ein bisschen betrüblich. Ich mache mich da ein bisschen lustig drüber, stimmt. Aber es ist auch einfach ähm,
Es betrügt mich so ein bisschen wie hoch dann doch der Anteil an Menschen ist, die.
Deren Beitrag sich eben dann auch auf solche Kritik beschränkt. Und die sonst wenig wenig Wirkung erzielen.
Ja, ich denke, was man hier auch einfach mal äh sehen muss, ZPS ist am Ende äh ein Kunstprojekt. So, ja und das ist Kunst, weil Leute haben unterschiedliche Vorstellungen davon, was Kunst ist, was Kunst tun soll, was K.
Vor allem haben Leute wenig, wenig Vorstellung davon, dass sie gerade Teil dieser Kunst sind. Also wie wie,
Ich meine, wenn du dich darüber echauffierst, ja, dann meinst du das, dann sitzt das Zentrum für politische Schönheit da und sagt oh nein, äh jetzt ächerfiert sich jemand über das, was wir hier getan haben.
Darauf wollte ich hinaus, ja? Also es ist halt auch, dass es oder es sollte, dass Ziel guter, zumindest politischer,
Also erstmal sollte es auch gut, also Kunst ist ein breites Wort. Kunst kann alles sein, das kann irgendwie ein schönes, gemaltes Bild sein, es kann Sonntagsmalerei, eine Verklärung von was weiß ich sein,
geschenkt. Kunst kann aber auch und sollte aber auch ähm eine inhaltliche Avongad sein.
Wenn man sich ähm wo ich jetzt nicht sonderlich tief drin stecke, aber,
bestimmte äh gesellschaftliche Themen, die so diskutiert werden, die irgendwann hochkommen. Da stellt man nicht selten fest
dass die in Theaterkontexten, ja, bei progressiven Gruppen et cetera schon lange thematisiert worden sind, wo irgendwie vor zwei, drei, vier, fünf, äh, vielleicht zehn Jahren vorher Leute sich über diese ganzen Trends schon solche Gedanken gemacht haben und die ihrer Kunst zum Ausdruck gebracht haben, wie zum Beispiel in einem Theaterstück,
Aktionskünstler Wiss Zentrum für politische Schönheit tragen diese selbe Debatte.
In einer anderen Kunstform in die Öffentlichkeit und beim ZPS halt insbesondere in einer, wie ich finde einfach der
Zeit auch sehr angemessenen Form, ja? Durch Netzpräsenz, durch.
Digitale Aktivitäten, aber eben auch durch dieses vor Ort und natürlich reißen sie in dem Moment äh äh die Gesellschaft da auch ein wenig in Stücke, weil das ist das Ziel der ganzen Sache
darum geht es, denn erst dann fangen die Leute ja an, darüber auch wirklich nachzudenken. Wenn halt immer so ein bisschen, ja, ach nee, das finde ich jetzt mal nicht so gut und vielleicht könnte man ja nächstes Mal auch mal ein bisschen weniger AfD wählen
Ja, klar, aber damit sind wir ja nun nicht gerade besonders gut gefahren und nicht weit gekommen und äh vielleicht ist es eben auch erforderlich, dass wir äh Debatten überhaupt auch erst äh beginnen wirklich zu führen, solche Auseinandersetzungen zu machen, auch Auseinandersetzungen in diesem Fall eben über eine,
Person, die da jetzt eben besonders hervorsticht und ihr exemplarisch für diese gesamte Bewegung ist, äh äh zu führen, so. Und äh ihnen das ist es jetzt hervorragend gelungen, hier gleich mehrere
Gesprächsebenen zu eröffnen, ne? Die äh Diskussion über Überwachung, die Diskussion, über die Rolle der Geheimdienste, über äh.
Äh über Andenken äh an historische äh Missetaten äh die Bedeutung von von Denkmälern. Also der steckt ja so viel äh äh drin. Da kann man jetzt wahrscheinlich jahrelang irgendwie draus zehren
und ich bleibe äh bei meiner Sicht, die ich schon
Eingangs als wir das ursprünglich angesprochen haben so geäußert habe, ist einfach mal eine eine geile Aktion und ich ziehe meinen Hut äh vor
vor der Vehemenz und auch von der Bandbreite an Ideen und und und wie das alles durchgezogen wird, das einfach mal, wenn wir mehr davon hätten, dann wären wir besser aufgestellt.
Jetzt wird, wird äh dem, was du gerade gesagt hast, äh der Vollständigkeit habe, die Kritik entgegenkommen, dass äh hier nicht,
dazu geführt wurde, dass die AfD jetzt irgendwie einen schlechteren Stand hätte. Ähm ganz im Gegenteil,
Was ja sehr gut gelungen ist, ist äh irgendwie Opferhöcke, ne? Also er hat's ja sehr gut geschafft, sich da als Opfer zu stilisieren. Ähm
Auch das denke ich, hat die hat die hat das ZPS hier durchaus eingepreist, ja? Und gewusst, dass das natürlich passieren würde ähm und damit natürlich auch gespielt und hat die Aktion wird jetzt am Ende nicht,
Dazu geführt haben, dass die AfD auf einmal zwanzig Prozent weniger Wähler hat, ja? Aber ähm,
Das hat auch keine Aktion von irgendjemandem, der irgendwie Kritik an dieser Aktion übt, geschafft, ja? Ähm insofern hat die Aktion jetzt die Welt verbessert.
Weiß ich nicht. Ist sie in dem was sie was sie geschafft hat, wie sie die wie sie Gesellschaft den Spiegel das ist auch so eine abgedroschene Phrase ich könnte mich
Ohrfeigen dafür, das überhaupt gesagt zu haben, ja? Äh der Gesellschaft den Spiegel vorhalten, die Kunst. Also ich kann ja sowieso dieser Kunstbegriff, ich kann auch, ich rede auch nicht gerne über Kunst und ich höre noch weniger gerne Leuten zu, die über Kunst reden. Ähm.
Aber wenn etwas Kunst ist dann das.
Ja, also das zu schaffen in dieser in diesem Geniestreich der Verbindung unterschiedlicher Themen der Provokation von unterschiedlichen Reaktionen in der Gesellschaft. Das ist äh.
Das ist halt ein, das den würde ich wenigstens sagen, das ist der hat den das Level an Kunst erreicht,
das zu schaffen. So eine Situation in einer Gesellschaft vorzufinden und zu sagen so, hm da den Knopf drücke ich jetzt.
Ja und meine kann auch sein, dass das alles auch erst sehr viel äh später in seiner Bedeutung richtig erfasst wird. Meine das Ganze steht in der besten Tradition äh von so Leuten wie Christoph Schlingsief zum Beispiel, ja? Der wäre ja noch am Leben sicherlich hier äh seinen,
Spaß an dieser ganzen Aktion gehabt hätte, ja? Das kann man jetzt natürlich auch einfach mal unterstellen, aber wenn man sich mal so die ganzen Aktionen, weiß nicht, hatten wir das,
schon angesprochen, haben wir glaube ich schon angesprochen, ne? Diese ganzen Aktionen so scheitern als Chance und und wir äh die Arbeitslosen schwimmen jetzt hier mal zu Helmut Kohl irgendwie an sein Ferienhaus über den See,
das ist ja wo was haben die da auch alle für eine Angst gehabt und geschwitzt gehabt, aber,
Das hat halt einfach diese ganze Frage mit irgendwie äh ja welche Bedeutung hat denn das so, ne? Oder dieses wir wir machen jetzt hier so Big Brother mit äh Asylsuchenden und wer wird denn das jetzt rausgewählt und so.
Dass das thematisiert hat einfach alles.
Dass jetzt diese wenigen Leute jetzt nicht irgendwie unsere ganze Gesellschaft von äh heute auf morgen äh komplett umkippen. Ja
Macht euch darüber Gedanken, warum eigentlich, ja? Warum warum schaffen die denn das äh äh damit nicht? Weil wir vielleicht diesem ganzen Thema einfach nach wie vor zu wenig Aufmerksamkeit geben.
Das Schöne, was all diesen Aktionen gemein ist, dass dann immer irgendeiner aufsteht und sagt, das ist aber menschenverachtend und,
Das Spannende daran ist, wer das sagt, das ist eigentlich das, was all diese Aktion gemeint ist, ne, dass dann irgendeine also welche Leute dann auf einmal aufstehen, mit welchem Hintergrund, mit welchem, mit welchem moralischen Ballast auf ihrer Seele dann sagt, du, das ist aber menschenverachtend, wo du denk,
Nun ja kommen wir zum ach so.
Wir kommen jetzt zum ersten Thema eigentlich.
Das gibt dreiviertel Stü.
Also wir noch nicht was ganzes kommt noch eins. Wir haben ja wir haben ja nach Themenwünschen und was wir in Logbuch Netzpolitik mehr machen sollen. Das haben wir jetzt einfach mal aufgenommen, wahrgenommen. Da gab's auch mehrere, also das Feedback war hier,
Durchaus überschneidend. Also da gab es die Wünsche, die kamen, wurden,
Oft von mehreren Leuten genannt, wir nehmen das zu Herzen, werden das umsetzen.
Dazu auch am Ende der Sendung nochmal mehr. Ähm wiederholte Themenwünsche waren Bitcoin, Bildungspolitik und äh China.
Die Onest Man, diese ganzen Geschichten. Für für Bitcoin will ich jetzt erstmal bis auf weiteres auf die aktuelle Freakshow verweisen, obwohl ich die noch gar nicht gehört habe, aber mir wurde geflüstert, dass es größtenteils um Bitcoin ging.
Ja, wir hatten diesmal ein relativ äh dickes Segment, was ich diesem ganzen Hype äh nochmal ähm zugewendet hat
und mal so ein paar
Analysen des Ist-Zustands und so weiter machen, wobei ich glaub die Fragen hier gingen halt dann doch eher weniger um, wie kann ich jetzt irgendwie meine äh äh Bitcoins buchen und wie funktioniert die Blockchain sein? Hier ging's glaube ich auch so ein bisschen mehr ums Meterthema,
sicherlich nochmal wert, dass in irgendeiner Form aufzuarbeiten ich kann auch gar nicht behaupten, dass ich mir.
Dieses Mitterthema selber, so, dass mir da so sicher bin, dass ich weiß, wie ich darüber äh äh denken soll,
Wir beobachten hier auf jeden Fall etwas, was äh weitreichende Konsequenzen hat, aber ich kann noch nicht genau sagen, welch.
Also das Thema haben wir, wir haben diese Themen auf unsere Liste aufgenommen und äh wollen die nur eben auch dann mehr mit Vorbereitung und,
und Besuch behandeln. Ähm Thema China, da wäre das eine wunderbare Überleitung zum vierunddreißig C drei, der ja vor der Tür steht.
Und die ist ja in China stattfinde.
Na fast.
Ja, fast. Leipzig. Leipzig.
Leipzig in Leipzig stattfindet. Ähm, wer da in der Fahrplan wurde jetzt äh kürzlich released ähm.
Und da haben wir ähm,
da haben wir das Thema auch drin vertreten. Es wird beim vierunddreißig C3 auch dieses Thema Onest Man und die die neue Gamie-Fight Control in in China gehen. Ähm,
Wir haben aber noch viele weitere Themen.
Die davor kommen und da ich ja an der Programmauswahl beteiligt bin, ziere ich mich ja immer zu irgendwie Highlights oder sonstiges zu,
zu benennen im Programm, deswegen ist einfach die Empfehlung äh geht auf äh Tim, du suchst gerade in dem Ding rum, der Link ist einfach,
Events, die CD Slash Congress Slash zwanzig siebzehn Slash Fahrplan. Ähm
Auch der natürlich in den in den Shownots. Schaut euch das an. Ist wirklich ein ein Riesenprogramm wieder. Ähm,
Klick mal kurz auf Tag eins, vielleicht kommen ein paar sagen, och guck mal, Eröffnung. Nee. Tim, du machst die Eröffnung, wer hätte das gedacht.
Tja, es ist wieder bei drei nicht rechtzeitig auf dem Baum.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob wir äh überhaupt das Motto in diesem Rahmen schon äh gewürdigt haben. Also der Condor steht dieses Jahr unter dem Motto Tuwat und ähm.
Wie auch schon im vergangenen Jahr war ich an dieser Motorentscheidung nicht unbeteiligt.
Und das äh ist ein der Bezug, der vielleicht vielen gar nicht äh so klar ist, ist welcher Tim? Tu was.
Es bezieht sich auf ein äh Dokument, ein äh eine Anzeige im,
hat's vor mittlerweile, ne? Sechsunddreißig Jahren, neunzehnhunderteinundachtzig. Ja, der äh
Tuward Punkt TXT überschrieben äh von der Touchs dann leider im Satz etwas verunstaltete äh Titel ähm war halt diese Anzeige,
zu einem Treffen aufgerufen wurde,
wo sich Leute treffen sollten, die Interesse an Computerthemen hatten und sich doch mal treffen sollten,
Denn äh wir wollen jetzt mal was tun und weiß nicht, wie weit wir jetzt hier ausholen sollten. Ich habe da ein ähm.
Damals noch Chaos, Radio Express äh vollgemalt zugemacht mit dem
Namen, Tuwa, TXT, wo ich halt Leute, ähm die an dem Treffen, die das Treffen mit vorbereitet haben, teilweise dran teilgenommen haben, äh gemacht haben,
wäre sicherlich genau die Sendung gewesen, die man mit äh Wau Holland mal hätte machen müssen, der aber nun leider zweitausendeins schon verstorben ist zu unserer aller Trauer
und deswegen ist es auch etwas schwierig diese Geburtsstunde des Clubs, die letztlich daraus ja auch resultierte festzumachen. Gibt's auch gerade in den letzten Tagen nochmal durch ein paar Gespräche versucht, das genauer zu verorten,
man muss sagen, auch wenn quasi neunzehnhunderteinundachtzig irgendwie so als Kick-Off-Datum und so ein eigentlicher Clubgeburtstag gefeiert wird, ist wahrscheinlich doch eher so, dass der
Club, wie man ihn heute kennt. Tatsächlich neunzehnhundertvierundachtzig äh richtig Fahrt aufgenommen hat, da sind dann sozusagen die,
Erster Kongress, Datenschleuder, erste äh Hack und so weiter, Bildschirmtext. Das ist eigentlich schon in gewisser Hinsicht ja auch das angemessene Jahr, vielleicht sollte man da auch mal unsere historische Aufzeichnung etwas
bearbeiten, nichtsdestotrotz tu was quasi eine Antwort auf die TUNIX Kongresse, die es damals gab.
Und zwar nicht nur in Form des äh nicht nur in Form des CC, das ging ja noch viel weiter in den Kultuwattkongressen in Berlin, in der Hausbesetzerszene.
Genau, die wohl nicht so erfolgreich waren, aber äh die ähm ja äh letzten Endes auch eine äh Reaktion waren.
Letzten Endes,
Wort, was wunderbar als Motto passt, denn wir denken, dass eben.
Jetzt tun wir mal wieder was. Äh ist durchaus ein Aufruf, den wir hier in unser erweitertes Umfeld geben wollen.
Dass die innere Sicherheit erst durch Computereinsatz möglich wird, glauben die Mächtigen heute alle
Das Computer nicht streiken, setzt sich als Erkenntnis langsam auch beim mittleren Unternehmen durch. Das durch Computereinsatz das Telefon noch schöner wird
glaubt die Post heute mit ihrem Bildschirmtextsystem in Feldversuchen beweisen zu müssen. Dass
Personal Computer. Nun in Deutschland dem video gesättigten BMW-Fahrer angedreht werden soll, wird durch die nun einsetzenden Anzeichen Anzeigenkampagnen klar
Dass sich mit Kleincomputern trotz alledem sinnvolle Sachen machen lassen,
die nicht, die keine zentrierten Großorganisationen erfordern, glauben wir,
damit wir als Computerfreaks nicht länger unkoordiniert vor uns hinwuseln, tun wir wat und treffen uns am zwölften neunten einundachtzig in Berlin Wattstraße. TAZ Hauptgebäude ab elf Uhr. Wir reden über internationale Netzwerke, Kommunikationsrecht
Datenrecht. Wem gehören meine Daten? Copyright, Informations und Lernsysteme, Datenbanken, Entkryption,
Computerspiele, Programmiersprachen, Process Control, Hardware und was auch immer. Tom Twitterbit,
Wau, Wolf und zwei Ungenannte.
Ja, das war der.
Machen wir seit der hat sich nichts geänder.
Das hat sich äh äh nix geändert. Ja, eine eins der einzige Begriff, mit dem man vielleicht etwas fremdeln könnte, ist Process Control, der sich im Wesentlichen damals auf so Hardware Hardwaresteuerung äh wirklich bezog, was ja jetzt auch noch äh durchaus ein Thema ist, wenn man sich die ganze
Bewegung anschaut. Also mit anderen Worten hier ist vor knapp vierzig Jahren.
Ach so, es gibt einen Punkt. Äh eine Sache, die sich auch erledigt hat, ist äh Datenrechtfinden gehören meine Daten. Facebook.
Das hat sich auch inzwischen geklärt.
Ja
Ähm.
Ja, weil es ist alles erschreckend aktuell, ne? Also das ist äh immer wieder faszinierend und äh die Truppe war ja auch selber, das aufgesetzt hat, da,
Twitterbild und Konsorten waren selber ganz überrascht wie wie gut das sozusagen den den Test der Zeit,
überlebt hat, ne? Weil ich meine mal ehrlich, also weder fehlt da irgendwie viel, noch ist irgendwas unangemessen, noch noch noch blickt irgendwas in eine falsche Zukunft und wie gesagt, das ist äh glaube ich umso jünger man ist,
Umso schwerer ist das nachzuvollziehen wie visionär das war, weil man sich einfach immer wieder klar machen muss,
furchtbar und digital die Welt neunzehnhunderteinundachtzig war. Also die war einfach nahezu komplett,
undigital, was einfach neunundneunzig Komma neun neun Prozent der Menschen betrifft, so. Klar gab's,
im Computer so und natürlich waren wir da einundachtzig am Anfang der Home Computerbewegung, es gab ein paar Leute und so weiter
Das ist ja dann auch quasi diese erste Generation, die schon eben bei dem Erstkontak,
diesen Maschinen begann zu verstehen,
A, so ist das. Denken wir das doch mal kurz weiter
Programmieren, Daten speichern, so verhält sich das so. Was bedeutet das? Die also in der Lage waren quasi aus der überschaubaren Kontaktzeit, die man bis dahin mal mit solchen Systemen haben konnte.
Schon Schlüsse daraus zu ziehen
Okay, wie wirkt sich das aus, wenn das auf einmal überall ist? Und das ist überall ist, ist vielleicht die eigentliche Erkenntnis, dieses Gefühl und ich denke, dass war dieser ganze Hacker, Computerszene in den achtziger Jahren, die Leute, die dort zusammenkamen, waren schon so die Leute, die eigentlich geahnt haben, wow, das hat so viel Sog,
Wir sehen ja, wie das uns zieht und und und äh das es nicht vorstellbar, dass das nicht irgendwann mal überall ist.
Lass uns mal über internationale Netzwerke reden.
Ja, genau, also das ist irre, ja? Und,
dann auch eben schon so die Frage, mit wem, wem gehören die Daten, also das.
Hatten die meisten hatten noch gar keine. Also die meisten Leute hatten einfach noch keine Daten zu diesem Zeitpunkt.
Ja, das war auch noch sechs Jahre vor Volkszählungen und all diesen ganzen Sachen. Also es war ähm.
Wow, es war wirklich äh äh wow und hat einfach den.
War auch Holland, ja war das.
Wow, genau, ja. Ja und wow, um das vielleicht damit abzuschließen, Wau war eben.
Von allen beteiligten Personen, diejenige, die aus diesem Treffen heraus quasi am meisten äh Energie äh,
entwickelt hat, dann eben sozusagen auch was zu tun und äh aus diesem Tuwa Gedanken heraus,
zu irgendeinem Zeitpunkt, der sich,
wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr so genau festnageln lässt. Spätestens aber neunzehnhundertvierundachtzig quasi so den äh Chaoscomputerclub ausgerufen hat.
Und dann eben sich auch hat manifestieren lassen und dann eben relativ früh eine wirklich interessante äh Gruppe von Leuten zusammengezogen hat
die auch insofern, dass wir auch jetzt nochmal eine interessante Erkenntnis der letzten Tage, die auch insofern äh was Neues war, als dass sie eben auch in der Lage war
über gesellschaftliche Grenzen hinweg die Leute zusammenzubringen. In dem frühen CC haben sich einfach Leute getroffen
sowohl aus wohlhabenden Hamburger Etablissement äh sozialen Gruppen heraus bestückt hat als eben auch,
Andere Leute wie Wau zum Beispiel, die hält so seiner tieflinken Prägung unterwegs waren, die sich aber alle sozusagen in diesen, ganz gut, in diesem, in dieser Anzeige zusammengefassten Gedanken haben treffen können und so fasziniert waren eben von dem
Möglichkeiten der der neuen Technologie, dass sie einfach, dass das äh einfach gar keine Rolle gespielt hat. Und diese,
breit breiter Aufstellung des äh Clubs, die sehe ich auch heute noch. Beziehungsweise habe gesehen, dass es in den letzten zehn zwanzig Jahren eben diesen Club,
Maßgeblich äh geprägt hat, dahingehend, dass wir einfach äh eine sehr breite Verankerung auch in dieser Gesellschaft haben. Schon immer hatten, ja? Also es gab.
Gab die Philosophen und es gab irgendwie die Anwälte, es gab die Techniker und es gab die Künstler und es war
schon immer diese gesamte Bandbreite, die es ausgemacht hat und die vielleicht auch den Club in die Lage versetzt hat, gesellschaftliche Trends eben auch einfach mal so klar zu benennen und zu zu,
Büren und und da dann eben auch entsprechende Schlussfolgerungen draus zu ziehen und sich dieser Debatte zu stellen. Eben weil man da eben so heterogen aufgestellt war.
Ja, also.
Werden dann hier die Selbstbeweihräucherung Ende des Jahres dann abschließen.
Jetzt vielleicht erstmal nur so viel dazu. Fahrplan ist da, schaut mal rein.
Schaut mal rein.
Kommt rum. Sendezentrum gibt's auch wieder, allerdings nicht in der Besuchern der letzten,
Veranstaltung, vier Veranstaltungen, bekannten Formen. Wir mussten uns dieses Jahr entscheiden, dieses Konzept der großen Bühne mal sein zu lassen,
weil das uns einfach organisatorisch äh über den Kopf wuchs und äh schlicht die Leute diesmal nicht so zur Verfügung standen,
da tut uns 'ne Auszeit auch mal ganz gut mal ein bisschen Saro zu reflektieren was wir da eigentlich beitragen können an der Stelle aber es gibt das Sendezentrum als Community Ort als Esambly da könnt ihr hinkommen, es gibt ein Podcaster Tisch, da werden die ganze Zeit Sendungen aufgenommen und natürlich sind viele Leute da vom Podler, von Ultraschall, von all diesen ganzen
Projekten, denen es also irgendwie interessiert, da vorbeikommen, insbesondere Entwickler, die vielleicht Lust haben,
ähm unsere Projek,
äh voranzubringen, mal gerne gesehen, da hatten wir im letzten Jahr schon einen sehr erfolgreichen äh Neukontakt. Ähm und äh ja
das fände ich natürlich super, mich werdet ihr dort äh sicherlich häufiger finden. Ansonsten sind wir ja auch aufm,
Kongress zu finden. Zum Beispiel über das tolle interne Telefonsystem ja kann man mich auch.
Ich bin eigentlich ganz,
dass die Nummer selten gewählt wird von Leuten, die also das Telefon klingelt eh die ganze Zeit. Also ich bin eigentlich gerade ich ich bin gerade komm ich auch zum Ende nochmal zu, ich will eigentlich nicht mehr das Geräte klingeln. Ich will auch nicht mehr, dass E-Mails kommen.
Datenfrust. Na gut, aber ich meine für mich ist der Kongress auch ein äh primär vor allem ein ein,
soziales Netzwerking äh Event und wer irgendwas Produktives beizutragen hat oder so, kann mich da gerne äh über eins, zwei, drei, vier anrufen.
Eins, zwei, drei, vier, der Tim wieder mit einer Tim wieder mit der Vanity Nummer schlechthin, ne? Meinen, soll ich meine Nummer sagen? Meine Nummer ist.
Wenn du, wenn du, wenn du angerufen werden möch.
Ich werde es ganz ehrlich sagen, also.
Ich habe jetzt schon wieder wirklich Sorge vor der, also jetzt gerade schon wirklich seit Wochen wieder stressig ist mit diesem Kongress und auch vor Ort gerade an Tag eins nicht weniger stressig wird.
Ich habe im Prinzip ähm,
die die Tage eins und zwei gestrichen, an Tag eins ist irgendwie erst Pressebetreuung abends mit äh Thorsten und Martin Vortrag über den Bundeswahlhack. Bundestagswahlhack ähm.
Am zweiten Tag ist der Jahresrückblick und dann habe ich wahrscheinlich mein Pensum erfüllt,
Und dann habe ich quasi den dritten und vierten Tag.
Habe ich frei. Und wer am dritten oder vierten Tag äh Lust hat, mich zu äh grüßen, ist herzlich dazu eingeladen und die Telefonnummer ist die zwei fünf acht neun. Das ist das große L. Ich habe nämlich auch eine Venetynummer.
L of Tastatur.
Äh man muss dazu sagen, der der Ruf der gesamte Rufnummerblock, der mit eins anfängt, ist nur eine nur mit besonderem Status zu erlangen. Deswegen war der Nummer mit zwei an.
Nicht eins, zwei, drei, vier, sondern eins, zwei, drei, fünf nehmen sagen, dann hätte ich das T.
Passt schon.
Ähm.
Sendezentrum haben wir. Ach so, was glaube ich ist jetzt immer schwierig Sachen zu zu plangen, ne? Aber was ich ganz witzig finde, wo ich mich echt äh freue, ähm,
Mark Uwe Kling kommt und äh liest aus seinem Buch Qualityland. Und wie zumindest eine Person von euch weiß, habe ich das kürzlich als Hörbuch gehört,
Äh und äh das ist auf jeden Fall nochmal ein kleiner äh Geschenktipp für Menschen, die äh vielleicht das Thema kennen, dass man.
So ein bisschen wie sind zukünftige Entwicklungen, wem gehören meine Daten internationale Netzwerke und so,
Dass da humoristisch aufbereitet und ich glaube allgemein verständlich äh rübergebracht ist und ähm.
Das Buch gibt's in einer hellen und in einer dunklen Vers.
Ja, die unterscheiden sich allerdings nur durch die Werbeunterbrechung,
Und zwar sind bei der bei der dunklen Version sind die Werbeunterbrechungen dystopisch, bei der hellen Version sind die Verunterbrechung utopisch,
Es ist wirklich also ganz es ist wirklich liebevoll gemacht und wer Fan des Kängurus ist, wird da auch in einem Charakter ähnlichkeiten erkennen, ähm aber es ist, man erkennt auch, wenn man sich mit den Themen jetzt so so tief auseinandersetzt
tiefe Auseinandersetzung seit Jahren, erkennt man auch, dass es so ein bisschen,
Die Behandlung dieser Themen auch gebaut ist, ne? Also die Storyline findet statt und es gibt dann immer so Exkurse. Historische Exkurse.
Ja, also damals,
Hieß, da gab's sowas, das hieß Facebook oder sowas, ne,
Kurse in die Biometrie, Exkurse in die autonomen Systeme Exkurse in,
Die Aufrechterhaltung des Kapitalismus nachdem wirklich einfach alle Arbeitsplätze wegautomatisiert wurden und ähm
Auch diese Nähe zu diesem China-System, das ist da schon sehr sehr gut gelungen dieses Buch und das kann man auf jeden Fall einfach mal empfehlen.
So als auch als Geschenk, ja? Durchaus Geschenkempfehlung,
Schöner konsumieren mit Lokbuch, Netzpolitik.
Ganz ohne das Mark Uwe uns dafür bezahlt.
Genau rufen sie jetzt die Nummer neben ihrer Landesflagge an und äh genau, ich ähm.
Muss er, also ich freue mich da, ich freue mich da tatsächlich drüber und habe ähm werde dieses Buch auch verschenken. Sag aber noch nicht wem.
Links in den Shownots.
Genau, es sind jetzt Shownotes verlinkt, wer da noch eine, wer da noch Geschenkempfindung braucht. Ansonsten ähm Social Score ist drin, E Privacy Verordnung ist drin, Max Schrems ist drin, mit seiner neuen NGO, braucht man alles hier gar nicht mehr zu behandeln und können damit jetzt aber endlich,
Zum ersten Thema kommen.
Oh Gott.
Mit drei zu zwei Stimmen wurde am Donnerstag in den USA die Bestzeitradität wieder
abgeschafft beziehungsweise der Beschluss gefasst
das jenes geschehen sollte und zwar hat er abgestimmt die Regulierungsbehörde FCC, Fatworl Communications Commission und äh wir erinnern uns, dass sich das Jahr anbahnt, das war ein großes
großes Thema in den USA, es war klar mit.
Mit der Auswahl Donald Trumps für die neue, für den neuen Share, der FCC,
war klar, dass das ein jemand ist, der sehr stark gegen die bestehende Netzneutralitätsregulierung in den USA
ist und Eintritt und äh der,
Die FCC ist also quasi so aufgebaut, dass du zwei, dass du fünf Personen hast und damit ist quasi der,
Share dann der Thaibreaker, ne? Der im Prinzip selber entscheiden kann, weil er zu seiner zu beiden Seiten zwei äh Leute hat, die dann irgendwie.
Leute hat, die dann irgendwie.
Quasi. Schon klar ist, in welcher Tradition die stehen,
Interessant ist, wir haben es auch in der letzten Sendung schon angesprochen, dass das unter dem Namen der Freiheit lief, ja? Der Restoring Internet Freedom Act,
es Freiheit ist natürlich klar, Freiheit ist immer auf Freiheit des Kapitalismus. Freiheit ist immer auch Freiheit der Unternehmen und ähm diese Freiheit sollte hier wieder hergestellt werden. Es gab,
Vierundzwanzig Millionen Eingebungen, ja, bei der, bei der FCC. Ähm es gab kein einziges öffentliches Hering, keine einzige Anhörung von Sachverständigen oder so.
Eingaben. Eingebungen hatten sie glaube ich nicht so viel.
Eingebung hatten sie nur eine.
Eingebung hatten sie nur eine, vierundzwanzig Millionen Eingaben, also Stellungnahmen aus der Zivilgel,
Gesellschaft mit Abstand, dass das meist kommentierte Verfahren in der Geschichte der FCC.
Ähm allein zwei,
Millionen dieser Eingaben sind mit gestohlenen Identitäten eingereicht worden, also haben irgendwelche Menschen, die seit zwanzig Jahren tot sind, äh teilweise Menschen mit russischen E-Mail-Adressen, das ist äh auch irgendwie klar. Ähm.
Ähm fünfzigtausend äh fehlen,
einfach untergegangen, also sehr komisch wie das da gelaufen ist.
Und ähm natürlich klar die von diesen Toten und so waren dann irgendwie von Leuten die ähm.
Also die hatten natürlich dann die, die waren pro Abschaffung der Netzneutralität. Es gab eine Reihe an Astroturfing, irgendwie sowas wie die, was weiß ich, die die,
hispanischen Kanalarbeiter für das Euro-Rating oder sowas, ne? Also irgendwie so
wo sich dann die Lobbyorganisationen einfach mal neue gegründet haben, die irgendwie so tun sollten als wenn sie hier für die für die Rechte der armen Schwachen einstehen.
Und ähm so wurde dann eben wie vorhersehbar war, dass diese diese Eingaben,
Sind denen ja völlig egal. Äh entsprechend wurde auch äh abgeschlossen, abge,
Stimmt. Es gibt einen äh ich erinnere mich an ein klares Feedback, dass gesagt wurde, ja, zum Thema Netzneutralitäten möge man d,
auch bitte stimmen gegnerische Stimmen zulassen. Ich denke der größte, bekannteste und einflussreichste Gegner der.
Der Netzneutralität ist Ajit Pay, der,
Share, der FCC, der die, der diese Abstimmung und diese Entscheidung zu verantworten hat. Er sagt, die zweitausendfünfzehn beschlossene Regelung der Netznetzneutralität durch die FCC ist ein Fehler, denn es habe,
kein zu lösendes Problem gegeben zu diesem Zeitpunkt.
Ähm die Bürger hätten sich nämlich nicht darüber beschwert, dass ihnen blockiert, dass ihnen Inhalte blockiert worden wären.
Sondern sie hätten sich beschwert über fehlenden Zugang oder zu geringen Wettbewerb,
Und die Regulierung habe nun dazu geführt, dass die Investitionen in Breitbandnetz und Milliarden äh um Milliarden von Dollar zurückgegangen sind. Ähm also ähm,
Die kleineren Anbieter seien mit den Regeln überfordert gewesen. Also seine Argumentation ist, weil es keinen, weil es Netzneutralität gab, wo in kleineren Anbietern äh waren jetzt überfordert, denen zu entsprechen.
Gleichzeitig hätte es kein Problem gegeben, denn es hätte ja vorher schon Netzneutralität gegeben. Also die Argumentation beißt sich hier so ein bisschen in den Schwanz.
Ähm die wahre Bedrohung für das offene Internet seien die zu nicht die Zugangsanbieter, sondern die Diensteanbieter.
Unter ihnen insbesondere das Silicon Valley Valley, das sich für die Netzneutralität einsetzt. Also er sagt, die Gefahr für das offene Internet ist das Silicon Valley,
würde ich sogar auch sagen.
Also da ist auf jeden Fall was dran, aber äh das sind etwas sehr genereller äh Begriff.
Die Frage ist, wenn wenn das Silicon Valley die Gefahr für das wie kann das Silicon Valley überhaupt die Gefahr für das für das offene Internet sein? Wenn ob das Internet offen ist oder nicht von den Zugangsprovidern entschieden wird,
Netzneutralität bedeutet, dass die Zugangsprovider keine Deals mit irgendjemandem auf dem anderen Ende des Internets machen dürfen, insbesondere nicht, mit denen die das Geld haben, also mit dem Silicon Valley,
Also die Argumentation, ich kann ihr wirklich bei bei aller Bemühung nur schwer folgen, aber ich gebe mir jetzt Mühe. Ähm.
Wirklich.
Wie entscheidet ein Unternehmen das Video? Ach so und dann natürlich,
dass das Video das das Silicon Valley Valley wäre natürlich jetzt hier die sind diejenigen die,
über die Redefreiheit entscheiden, das muss man immer wissen in den USA wird viel viel mehr über Redefreiheit argumentiert,
als über äh als irgendwie die also ein, als in Deutschland, ja? Also in Deutschland hast du ähm,
Eine andere Regulierung in andere Gesetzgebung zu der Idee der Meinungsfreiheit. Bei uns ist es Meinungsfreiheit. Äh wir setzen aber auch Meinungen an bestimmten Stellen klare Grenzen,
sagen bestimmte Sachen sind einfach keine Meinung mehr.
Weil die sind Fakten und die kann man dann halt nicht leugnen.
Genau, in den USA hast du Redefreiheit, kannst sagen, was du willst. Ähm und natürlich auch die Redefreiheit von Unternehmen darfst du natürlich nicht einschränken.
Und da sagt er quasi, also die Einschränkung findet auf den Plattformen statt, die Gefahr der der Meredefreiheitseinschränkung findet in den Plattformen statt und nicht in der Netzneutralität. Auch da würde ich ihm unter äh
Inzwischen vorsichtig zustimmen,
ja? Das natürlich eher bei den großen Inhalteplattformen die Frage der Meinungsfreiheit oder der Redefreiheit eine Rolle spielt als unbedingt bei äh bei den Zugangs,
Anbietern, aber wenn ein Zugangsanbieter Inhalte, Anbieter unterschiedlich behandelt, dann ist das eine, also dann wird da der freie
Austausch der Meinung angegriffen. Das heißt, da geht's gar nicht mehr um eine konkrete Meinung, sondern da geht's um um die Bedingungen unter den Meinungen überhaupt noch stattfinden kann,
Und das ist natürlich wieder das Einschneiden der Argument. Ähm,
Also wie gesagt, ich habe jetzt versucht, diese Meinung zu würdigen, ich kann, ich kann es nicht verstehen, der einzige Punkt, den man hier ähm werten könnte, es ist,
Also der einzige Punkt, den er hier sagt ist, es gab noch kein ähm zu lösendes Problem, als diese Meinungsfreiheit,
als diese Netzneutralität entschloss entschieden wurde und da dem
glaube ich kann man faktisch einfach widersprechen. Natürlich gab es ein zu lösendes Problem. Du hast in den USA schon jetzt keine Konkurrenz mehr in diesem Markt, wie er selber auch feststellt, aber Netzneutralität aufzuheben.
Bedeutet, dass du die Konkurrenz
einschränkst und dass du Monopole forcierst und ausbaust und insbesondere auch die, die er hier als Problem benennt, die Zugangsprovider
erhält eine lange Rede darüber, dass sie äh äh dass die Inhalte, Anbieter, die Dienstanbieter das Problem sein und nicht die Zugangsprovider. Dann lautet doch die Antwort, wenn ich sage, natürlich und diese dieses Assessment teile ich. Problem sind die Diensteanbieter,
Dann möchte ich doch bitte verhindern, dass die Dienste eine Bieter jetzt sich auch noch die Zugangsanbieter kaufen,
das genau bedeutet Netzneutralität. Und deswegen glaube ich der gute Mann argumentiert hier am,
Thema vorbei und vor allem am Ziel vorbei, denn.
Dieses Video gesehen, was er noch dazu gemacht hat.
Nee, habe ich nicht. Ich versuche gerade.
Also der Adrid Peider hat da noch so ein mega peinliches Video, wo er irgendwie als Weihnachtsmann verkleidet irgendwie rumhampelt, irgendwie seventhings, you can still, du After, net nur tradity,
wo es mir schon gerade nicht gelingt, das Original überhaupt noch im Netz zu finden, weil das natürlich eine eine Mehm.
Oh nein, habe ich im Leben verpasst.
Äh nach sich äh gezogen hat. Ja, es ist äh besonders krass, weil er eben selber auch irgendwie unter anderem mit Internetneben arbeitet und so.
Alle im Schaffel und irgendwie andere Sachen, das ist wirklich äh mega crazy. Ich äh versuche gerade nochmal so äh das eigentliche Original zu äh finden, weil es einfach alles äh voll ist mit Überarbeitung dieses Videos.
Also die Argumentation ist äh such das mal raus. Die Argumentation ist, die sie anziehen ist es gab zweitausendfünfzehn keine Netzneutralität.
Und deswegen war es ein Fehler, die irgendwie festzuschreiben, das Internet ist so, wie es entstanden ist, toll, weil es so ist,
Und dafür brauchen wir nicht irgendwelche Regulationen. Das ist quasi die Argumentation, die von,
konservativen, also Marktliberalen ähm kommt. Nun ist dazu festzustellen, natürlich ist das Internet so entstanden, wie es ist, ohne dass es reguliert wurde,
aber da gab es auch noch nicht diese große Macht darin. Der Punkt ist, es gab die Idee, die Netzneutralität zu verletzen,
kommst du erst wenn du eine gewisse Marktmacht hast,
Solange sich in diesem Markt noch ausreichend Konkurrenz abbildet in dem was.
In der Varianz und der Variante und der Ausfall an Inhalteanbietern. Und in der Auswahl an äh Zugangsprovidern. Solange du da genug
Wettbewerb hast, wird keiner auf die Idee kommen, die Netzneutralität zu verletzen. Klammer auf, es haben welche versucht, Anfang der neunziger oder eher Ende der Neunziger
diese ganzen AOLs und die Onlines und Jahhu, die gesagt haben, komm, wir bauen hier irgendwie das mit diesem Internet, ist viel zu chaotisch, wir machen das mal ordentlich für euch und die haben's halt nicht geschafft,
Das heißt, dieses Geschäftsmodell ist gescheitert und das haben sich auch alle gemerkt,
Und deswegen hat hat es dann auch weitere zehn Jahre niemand nochmal versucht bis auf einmal Unternehmen,
finanziell und von der Marktmacht an der Rolle waren, dass sie das jetzt machen konnten. Und dass sie jetzt sagen konnten, ist, so, jetzt halten wir zu beiden Seiten die Hände auf und jetzt verbinden wir,
unsere äh unsere Bestrebung einerseits für diesen Zugang zu kassieren und andererseits auch für Inhalte. Und wenn wir beides tun,
Dann haben wir nämlich eine marktbeherrschende Stellung und dann wird uns keiner mehr quer kommen und dann können wir die Preise hier gestalten und das Angebot gestalten, wie wir es möchten und sorgen dafür, dass wir an allem, was es irgendwie hier gibt, verdienen. Dieser.
Unterschied zu Beginn des Internets kann er nur immer sagen Bezug auf jeden Fall wichtigstes Buch zu dem Thema Tim Ruh, äh, The Master Switch,
ähm das war quasi das hast du bei jedem neu entstehenden Markt, dass du anfangst
sehr viel Wettbewerb hast, der automatisch stattfindet, der auch zum Besten des Kunden stattfindet und dann irgendwann einige weniger hast, die sich rauskristallisieren, die Monopol oder Olegopole
ähm bilden und dann diesen Markt unter sich aufteilen und dann natürlich zusehen müssen, dass sie den
mag der ihnen jetzt quasi gehört, den sie jetzt beherrschen, dass der weiterhin Geld abwirft. Und das ist,
natürlich, dass also dass auch das Verständliche, mich ganz ehrlich, das verständliche Bestreben
ähm dass ein Unternehmen, dass dessen Businessmodell Internetzugang ist kein,
Gesteigerten Wert darauf legt.
Sich dieses Milliardengeschäft hunderte tausende, was weiß ich, vertasteliardengeschäft Internet anzugucken und zu sagen, von jedem dieser Kunden, der über dieses Internet.
Was weiß ich? Zehn Euro Netflix, zehn Euro, Apple Music, zehn Euro,
Amazon Prime, ähm was weiß ich nicht alles und was weiß ich an Werbeeinnahmen noch an Google und Facebook,
umsetzt, von dem mit mageren fünfunddreißig Euro im Monat abgespeist zu werden. Das ist klar, dass das passiert, wenn du den Betrieb,
derartiger Infrastruktur in die Hände eines kapitalistisch motivierten Unternehmens legst, dann macht sucht es nach neuen Möglichkeiten Geld zu verdienen,
Die gibt es eben nur, wenn man, wenn man mit Neid auf die Dienste Anbieter schielt, dann denkt man sich, ah, es wäre aber wirklich geil, wenn wir da einfach nur ein bisschen was kein bisschen was mitverdienen würden, dann wäre doch alle, dann wären wir doch wieder happy und dann hätten wir auch
diesen diesen Scheiß mit den mit den Kabeln hier weiter zu betreiben. Das ist das, was dann passiert und deswegen muss das ähm,
verhindert werden, dass du diesen,
innere Interessenskonflikt aufbaust, weil er eben zu einer weil er dann letztendlich dazu führt, dass dein schönes Internet, was einmal so bunt war, wo jeder reinkonnte, wo jeder neue Ideen ausbauen, aufbauen konnte.
Zurück zum Fernsehen wird, zum besseren Fernsehen.
Das ist das, was leider hier gerade stattfindet. Jetzt gucken wir uns seventwings, you can still do on the Internet, Afternet Newtralety.
Man muss das wirklich anschauen.
After-Netnew-Traility oder Afternet Neutrality Camedown hat ja so seinen eigenen Titel nicht im Griff. Der AG.
Na ja, wenn wenn's dann erstmal, wenn's dann, nee, nee, das ist jetzt äh das Original. Also, ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie viel ähm wert das jetzt äh hat, äh das jetzt hier so ist, trotzdem mal anspielen.
Jetzt hast du so lange davon.
Na ja, ich dachte, ich pack's einfach in die Links, aber wir können ja mal.
Ich kenn's nicht.
Gut, schauen wir mal hier. Es steht ja so mit Fidget Spinner und irgendwie Wumme in der Hand.
Kannst aber noch Snapchat machen.
Ja die Frage ist nur wo checkt der das nicht? Der checkt das wirklich nicht, ne?
Das kaufen und konsumieren.
Es ist ziemlich schämlich auf jeden Fall der Herr.
Ey, du hast Recht, das Format nicht zu Ende zu gucken.
Und so weiter, Binch Watching und so weiter, es ist äh,
Im Wesentlichen sagt der, du kannst nach wie vor auf der äh Couch sitzen, Chips fressen und irgendwie Dinge äh äh kaufen und ein guter Konsument sein,
Erinnert mich an dieses wunderschöne Lied, äh, Revant your Soul.
Niemand, niemand redet davon, dass die Menschen jetzt am Konsumieren gehandelt werden, äh gehindert werden sollten.
Nee, darum geht's nicht. Es geht einfach bald Netzneutralisieren. Immer das Interessante ist, ne, äh immer bei den äh bei den Republikanern in den USA, dass sie halt immer so äh argumentieren, sie seien halt pro Business. Ja.
Das das wurde wurde ich gestern gefragt, ich habe ein kurzes Interview der Tagesschau gegeben zu dem Thema, ja? Und dann lautete eine Frage, na ja, die sagen alle, das ist gut für gut für gut for Business,
und meine Antwort darauf war, natürlich ist das gut fürs Geschäft. Die Frage ist nur wessen Geschäft so al.
Das hat für einige wenige Unternehmen nämlich im Wesentlichen diejenigen, die die Republikaner äh im Wahlkampf vorher mit Geld ausgestattet haben. Für die ist das gut.
Äh ganz klar ist das gut fürs Ge.
Und so Concast und so weiter äh wir finden das natürlich total super, dass das, was ihnen jetzt eigentlich die ganze Zeit untersagt wurde, nämlich ihren ähm,
ne, also ihren Vorteil, den sie quasi äh haben, ihr Privileg da mit dem äh Kabelzugang äh auszunutzen, irgendwie alle auch noch,
Dinge zu melken, mit denen sie halt eigentlich gar nichts zu tun haben. Das ist ja sozusagen eigentlich das Ding, ne? Sie dürfen halt Wegezoll nehmen und Wege Zoll wird halt jetzt äh legalisiert und das betrifft dann eben einfach nur die paar äh Unternehmen, die in dieser Situation sind, überhaupt wegezollt zu nehmen.
Genau die haben das eben äh finanziert, aber es ist halt nicht so, dass jetzt ein Internet
Business an sich daraus äh profitiert, weil das ist ja auch der die Kernidee beim bei Net Notrality in dem Moment, wo du alle gleich behandeln musst
heißt es, dass du eben auch alle Neulinge genauso behandeln musst, wie diejenigen,
gegeben den Fall, dass du eben in der Lage bist,
ein kreatives Angebot zu machen, was an den etablierten Plänen vorbei
auf Interesse stößt bei Kunden, dann gelingt es dir eben auch schnell groß zu werden, bestes Beispiel ist Netflix,
Wer hatte denn Netflix vor fünf Jahren aufm Zeiger? Niemand. So, da wurde halt also wann gibt's die seit fünf Jahren, ne?
Nee, nee, die gibt's sehr viel länger.
Okay, die haben ja erstmal mit ihrem DVD-Business angefangen, aber also alles nochmal als Netzphänomen, ne? Also sozusagen dieses Downloading und so weiter. Egal, jetzt äh Zeiträume sind jetzt eigentlich auch irrelevant, weil äh.
Wäre sozusagen äh Netflix nicht in der Situation gewesen an allen äh vorbei ihr Angebot einfach genauso gleich
berechtigt hinzustellen, ja? Und hätte sozusagen dafür bezahlen müssen, von vornherein überhaupt erstmal diese Zugänge zu bekommen
werden natürlich die Einstiegshürden äh so äh sehr viel größer gewesen und im Zweifelsfall eben auch so groß, dass äh äh vielleicht überhaup,
dieses Business so nie an Start bekommen hättest.
Das ist das, was ich auch immer nicht verstehe bei diesen, also bei dieser, bei dieser marktliberalen Idee, ja? Also mir ist völlig klar und ich also es ist nicht abzustreiten, dass in neuen Märkten, in den stehenden Märkten,
ähm du ein Level Playingfield hast,
und es können da Leute ähm zum Besten der Kunden konkurrieren. Ja? Also auch das mein ganz ehrlich, dass dass wir heute den Zugang zur Musik der Welt für,
ein Zehner im Monat kriegen,
Spotify oder sonst was, ähm ist das Ergebnis von, dass es keine Marktbeherrschenden Stellungen gab und dass es viel Wettbewerb gab und die von vornherein mit einem niedrigen Preis einsteigen mussten,
Das, da kann man sagen, hier, schau mal da, ne? Kapitalismus, geil, hat für den Kunden gearbeitet. So. In dem Moment, wo sich aber, wenn die, wenn die, wenn der Markt sich dann konsoliert und du einige wenige Player hast, die ihre Preise absprechen, so ungefähr.
Zufällig die gleichen Preise haben. Preisabsparen haben wir ja verboten. In dem Moment ist das ja einfach nicht mehr der Fall, dass das für den äh zum Vorteil des Kunden ist. Und da stellt sich doch dann die Frage, möchtest, möchtest du dann eigentlich als Regierung,
hingehen und sagen OK jetzt verhindern wir marktbeherrschende Stellung, so hab ich das eigentlich immer verstanden,
um den Wettbewerb aufrecht zu erhalten, um Konkurrenzaufwärts zu halten, damit wir dieses Positive, dieses, dieses liberalistische den Wettbewerb aufrecht erhalten können. Und jetzt verstehe ich nicht,
Warum diese Dyhard Marktliberalen hingehen und sagen äh nee Wettbewerb ist super, Wettbewerb ist super, insbesondere wenn's keinen mehr gibt.
So also ich verstehe das nicht. Ich kann, ich verstehe nicht, dass sie diesen Knick in der Logik nicht verstehen. Vielleicht kann mir das jemand in den in den ähm.
In den Kommentaren nochmal erk.
Versteht jedes Jahr auch, aber sie wollen halt einfach nicht, weil sie halt einfach bezahlt werden.
Freiheit, Freiheit.
Freiheit, Internet Freedom.
Ähm schau genau.
Viel mehr müssen wir dazu glaube ich nicht sagen oder.
Müssen da doch eine entscheidende Sache zu sagen, ähm denn.
Die Frage, die sie stellt ist, was bedeutet das für Europa? Da habe ich auch gestern noch ganz schnell den Thomas angerufen, um mir das nochmal genau erklären zu lassen. Situation in Europa.
Wir haben eine EU-Verordnung für Netzneutralität. Die hat gesetzartige äh Wirkung und die fällt auch nicht so schnell wie eine Behördenverordnung,
FC Leute wählen irgendwie einen anderen Präsidenten, der setzt irgendein an als Share der FC ein und zack äh ist die Behördenverordnung wieder weg. Das ist in Deutschland nicht der Fall.
Wir haben die Netzneutralitätsverordnung und da wird es zweitausendneunzehn einen ersten Bericht der Kommission geben, die denn diese Verordnung bewertet.
Und darauf wiederum einen Gesetzesvorschlag
formuliert und sagt, wir haben das jetzt mal angeguckt, also mit der Netzneutralität verläuft so und so. Wir finden, wir sollten die in der nächsten Verordnung folgendes machen, wir sollten ein Gesetz folgen, aber so geht's dann weiter, ja?
Am Himmel kommt jetzt schon auf, dass die, dass die Provider,
ankommen und sagen, ja, nee, diese ganzen, das,
dieses Netzneutralitätskonzept lässt sich auf 5G gar nicht mehr abbilden. Das heißt, die bauen ganz, ganz interessante Argumentationen, dass sie jetzt eigentlich sagen, wir bauen jetzt einfach eine neue Technologie,
gegen eure Gesetze verstößt und das heißt diese neue Technologie ist dann einfach mit euren Gesetzen nicht mehr abbildbar. Ähm, das heißt wir werden zweitausendneunzehn natürlich auch wieder die Diskussionen haben in Europa und da werden sie natürlich dann auch die USA als Beispiel heranführen,
Aber wir haben kein im unmittelbaren Zusammenbruch der äh der Netzneutralität in Europa. Was natürlich eine Rolle spielen wird, ist für deutsche und europäische Anbieter in den USA,
Die werden recht recht zackig. Äh dieses dieses Ende der Netzneutralität natürlich wieder zu spüren bekommen. Ähm.
Die FC, die die ähm die IFF oder der quasi das das große Bündnis für die Netzneutralität in den USA wird umgehend dagegen klagen und wir werden dieses Thema hier weiterverfolgen.
Genau, also das ist ja ohnehin jetzt der Trend in den letzten Monaten oder in diesem Jahr mittlerweile das ging viel von dem, was die Trump-Regierung versucht, durchzukriegen, äh extrem geklagt wird
Mit relativ viel Erfolg muss man sagen,
nicht äh auf allen äh Ebenen, weil gegen alles lässt sich nicht aus nicht auch ohne weiteres klagen, aber da wo es halt möglich ist, wird es eben auch äh getan und das hat dann eben auch mindestens einen verzögernden Effekt.
Inwiefern das jetzt hier greifen kann, weiß ich nicht. Es gibt auf jeden Fall wie auch eben bei den ganzen anderen Initiativen relativ viel Gegenwind von den ähm Bundesstaaten.
Also es gibt glaube ich so,
zehn, zwölf äh Bundesstaaten der USA, die da jetzt gegen äh vorgehen wollen, aber schon recht. Es kann sehr wohl sein, dass eben diese Debatte dann auch wieder nach Europa schwappt, auch wenn ich halt nicht glaube, dass jetzt also die Entscheidung der Trump-Regierung unbedingt jetzt hier äh als Mustervorlage
für alles gelten.
Hey, das ist immerhin jemand mit indischen Wurzeln, das ist doch hier in Divercity Thema. Ja. Besser Qualität ist einfach.
Ja wenn er dem dem Tram nach dem Maul redet, dann dann darf er auch mal eine andere Hautfarbe aber haben und wir aber danach darf er wahrscheinlich auch gehen, ne.
Als nächstes muss er die Mauer bauen.
Ein Lackaffe. Guckt euch mal dieses Video an, ist furchtbar, aber das das Netz ist voll mit äh.
Ist auch wirklich jetzt nicht so cool. Ich habe also.
Nein, nein, das ist nicht, natürlich ist es nicht cool, der Typ ist ja auch nicht cool, deswegen ist es ja auch so cheesey, aber äh lustig wird's, das habe ich aber jetzt noch nicht alles so durchgeschaut,
ganzen Verarschungen davon und irgendwie Cooperations genau du auf der Net-Nutrality et cetera. Also es gibt da sozusagen,
Ich kann jetzt bloß leider gerade nur den Originallink äh bieten, der erstmal langweilig ist, aber ist schon schießig genug, sowas, das, das hält sich das überhaupt äh traut.
Das Schöne ist an der Stelle, wo Tim gerade Pause gedrückt hat und die die ganze Zeit noch hier auf dem Bild vorzackern, da steht er da gerade mit einer Tüte Popcorn und äh und guckt einen Film, ja und das ist halt, dass du einfach so uramerikanisch, ne.
Es ist furchtbar.
Gucken und Popcorn essen. Ähm klagen im Bereich der Netzneutralität haben wir aber auch in Deutschland. Ja, Schaukuck.
Guck an. Ja. Und wer klagt eine Bürgerrechtsorganisation geht gegen.
Die Freiheit, die die Internetsfreiheitslobby, die die Internetsfreiheitsorganisation mit dem Namen deutsche Telekom A.
Klar gegen die Bundesnetzagentur. Wir erinnern uns, die Bundesnetzagentur hat gesagt, so erstens,
ungehindertenfreien Zugang zu zu Stream on für alle und zweitens vor allem im Ausland,
HD im Ausland muss halt natürlich auch gelten, denn wir haben ja die EU-Netz, wir haben ja die EU Roaming-Verordnung und das ist echt historisch dann doch irgendwie sehr amüsant, weil wir erinnern uns, dass
Eigentlich so die Netzneutralität gekippt werden sollte gegen die
Roaming Sache, ne? Es wurde irgendwie gesagt, ey jo, wir schaffen das, wir wir schaffen die Roaming-Gebühren ab,
Pfarrverordnung und die Netzneutralität aber auch. Das war so der,
der Trade auf der eh wie vor Jahren mal diskutiert wurde, jetzt sitzen sie da.
Und ähm.
Die äh dass die Bundesnetzagentur sagt halt, na ja, wenn ihr dieses machen wollt, ne, dann muss das natürlich auch in ganz Europa gelten, weil wir haben ja kein Roaming-Unterschiede mehr und,
Für diese Roaming-Sachen gibt es aber natürlich nur unter den Unternehmen trotzdem eine Verrechnung, ja?
Und wenn du äh der der liegt gerade bei sieben Komma sieben Euro pro Gigabyte,
Das heißt, wenn du ein äh Datenvolumen hast von ein Gigabyte,
Gehst da mit ins zahlst es bei ihr wieder im Provider.
Verbrauchst dieses Gigabyte im Internet, dann muss der sieben Euro siebzig dafür zahlen,
die er nicht zahlen muss, wenn du die zu Hause verbrätst.
Geht aber noch, weil die das natürlich quasi einkalkulieren. Deswegen hast du natürlich auch dann so eine Volumenbeschränkung noch drin, ne. Jetzt gehst du aber hin und hast Stream on.
Fährst in ein Land, wo du, wo du das wirklich nutzen könntest, also in Deutschland, sorry, ich habe geht ja nun auch nicht unbedingt an jeder Stelle, aber du könntest ja ähm,
In anderen Ländern, die haben ja funktionierende Infrastrukturen äh und jetzt geht's Gas zu der Stream on, gehst einen Monat ins Ausland,
europäische Ausland? Ja, Schweiz zum Beispiel, jetzt in die Schweiz. Ich glaube, da ist der LTE Empfang ganz gut und sagt Sky, Netflix, hier wie Adjet Py, ne? Tüte Popcorn.
Ist jetzt Non EU ein gutes Beispiel.
Schweiz gehört dazu zu dem EU-Rauming, hoffe ich.
Nein. Es ist sicher. Ja.
Bist du sicher? Ländergruppe eins.
Nein, das ist explizit, also ist das ausgenommen? Ja, ist nicht EU. Also Schweden.
Ist das ausgenommen? Ha okay, aber in allen anderen Angeboten, ich war jetzt relativ sicher, Holland auch, super, Holland hat ja auch Holland ist ein Infrastrukturstarkes Land. Das ist irre, was die da haben, das staunt so, was die für eine Infrastruktur haben.
Ja, alle sind Infrastruktur äh starkes Land außer äh äh Deutschland.
Unsere europäischen Freunde, guckst aber Netflix, Ballast, äh hier ist im Beispiel des Artikels, neunzig Minutigen HD Film bei fünf Mbit,
drei Komma drei sieben fünf Gigabyte müsste die Telekom halt sechsundzwanzig Euro zahlen.
Die sie dir nicht in Rechnung stellen kann. Ähm und jetzt nach dem.
So haben wir uns jetzt aber vorgestellt. Und das ist natürlich also das verfolge ich jetzt wirklich mit großem Interesse. Weil die BNI sagt, naja bei Verstößen.
Fünfhunderttausend Euro Zwangsgeld stehen im Raum, aber das Zwangsgeld kann auch dem äh dem wirtschaftlichen Vorteil dem, dass dem das verletzten Unternehmen hatte. Ähm,
angepasst werden, das heißt, es könnte auch höher sein,
Und äh die Telekom sagt natürlich, ja, ist ja unglaublich, ne? Wir haben hier so ein schönes Angebot und die und die Benetz A will jetzt irgendwie den Kunden das wieder wegnehmen, das kann ich mir ja wirklich nicht vorstellen. Also hier handelt die Benetzei doch wirklich nicht im Interesse des Kunden. Wir haben doch hier siebenhunderttausend
Streamer und Kunden, die das haben wollen und er ist jetzt wirklich unverständlich wie die deutsche Telekom da agiert.
Die sind doch so lieb zu allen.
Und die Frage, die man sich irgendwie bei dieser bei dieser bei diesen Ding stellt,
Bei dieser ganzen Streamer-Debatte, ja? Es gibt jetzt Leute, die sagen, ja, Streamer ist nicht die schlimmste Verletzung der Netzneutralität. Das Blocking von Voiceover IP ist ein schlimmeres
Ein schlimmerer Verstoß oder so. Denn dem ich entgegenhalten würde, du verballerst aber halt nicht ein paar Gigabyte über Voice over IP,
es ist ganz richtig, eine eine Sperrung der letzten also eine Sperrung der des der Voice of Alpir Dienste anderer ist eine Verletzung der Netzneutralität ist dir
das Ausdrucken einer Stellung,
Nämlich unalt zwei. Insbesondere findet das natürlich bei denen statt, die dir für Telefonie noch was abnehmen,
Und deswegen ist das ein ist es absolut nicht akzeptabel. Und soll soll auch unbedingt bei ähm,
Bei der Benetz A zur Anzeige gebracht werden und darf so in der Form nicht stattfinden, ganz klar,
Aber was ich bei diesem Streamer echt nicht verstehe, die Telekom kann doch offenbar diese Volumina leisten.
Den die können doch offenbar es dir erlauben ganzen Monat Netflix zu gucken.
Und warum nehmen die ausgerechnet an Konkurrenten von Netflix oder nicht so Bandbreitenintensive Dienste davon aus? Warum? Ich verstehe das nicht.
Versteht es auch nicht.
Also mir ist die Motivation wirklich unklar. Ich meine, ich hatte einen Moment drüber nachgedacht, ob's irgendwas mit wir äh wollen, die Unternehmen äh äh motivieren, Peering Points äh mit dem Telekomnetz zu machen, aber das ist ja nicht noch nicht mal die Voraussetzung
So und vor allem schaffen sie sich ja auch nochmal ein Overheld damit, in dem Sinne ist auch alles äh verwalten, müssen diese ganzen Verträge müssen quasi äh
aufgesetzt, gehalten, äh, geprüft, äh, beobachtet werden, zwar das Fall halt auch durchgeklagt werden und am Ende äh liefern sie das halt alles äh kostenlos, zeigen eigentlich im Prinzip damit, dass es ja geht,
Ja, also man kann für diesen Preis quasi diese Daten liefern. So und es wird ja den anderen Unternehmen dafür nichts abgenommen. Also wenn's geht, warum dann nicht für alle. Also ich ich verstehe auch ehrlich gesagt das nicht.
Mir irgendwie vielleicht hat äh also wenn wenn hier von unseren Hörerinnen und Hörern irgendjemand dann schlüssige.
Erklärung hat, wir sind da, tappen da gerade ein bisschen im Dunkeln.
Gerne auch auf der das ist die Frage für den Anberufbeantworter heute. Wenn ihr, wenn ihr darauf eine eine Antwort wisst.
Eine gute. Oder eine unterhaltsame.
Entweder oder.
Sieben Dinge, die du mit Stream One gucken kannst oder so. Na, eine gute Antwort. Also das ist, das ist ja hier der ähm dann bitte, ich ich null drei null.
Einhundertzwanzig achtundachtzig drei achtundachtzig. Bitte, also würde uns echt interessieren. Na, äh du lachst.
Lache. Optimum. Das müssen wir ändern. Egal. Ja, nee, passt schon.
Wieso denn? Ein Schäm, der böses dabei denkt.
Erstmal weitermachen.
Ja
Noch hier. Ja, unser Innenminister.
Backdoor everything. Ich find's schön, der Thomas in Thomas de Maizire ist nicht mehr Innenminister, der ist geschäftsführender Innenminister.
Ja, Entschuldigung, Geschäftsführender Innenminister.
Äh und der hat sich jetzt, der hat festgestellt, oh ja, also wir müssen ähm wir müssen jetzt mal die Industrie verpflichten, deutschen Sicherheitsbehörden, digitale Einfallstore für das Ausspionieren von,
privaten Autos, Computern und Smart TVs zu öffnen.
Und der Grund, der der Grund, den er dafür benennt, ist, na ja, den modernen Schließanlagen von Fahrzeugen sind mittlerweile so abgesichert, dass ihre Besitzer schon bei kleinsten Erschütterungen über Messenger-Dienste informiert würden.
Ja? Und er möchte unter anderem zum Beispiel diese.
Geplanten automatisierten Mitteilung unterbinden können.
Mit anderen Worten, ey, BMW, dein Auto schickt eine SMS an, den Besitzer, wenn wieder unsere Abhörwanze dran knallen,
schalte das mal bitte kurz fünf Minuten ab. Wir gehen da mal eben dran. Und.
Die Industrie soll also dem Staat exklusiv das natürlich nicht für andere, ne? Nur für uns, exklusive Zug ist Rechte einräufen, etwa bei Tablets, Computern, Smart TVs oder äh digitalisierten Küchengeräten,
Küchenwaage. Voraussetzung bleibt natürlich der Richterbeschluss.
Klar, damit ist das ja auch alles total sicher.
Und die aus, der Hintergrund ist äh finde ich auch mal interessant, dass sie wenigstens mal Zahlen nennen. Dann sagt er, im Jahr zweitausendsechzehn konnten wir in fünfundzwanzig Fällen einen richterlichen Beschluss zum Abhören eines Autos nicht umsetzen,
Weil die Autotechnik Alarm schlug als die Ermittler einer Abhörwanze anbringen wollten,
Ähm.
Interessant, dass sie die Dinger überhaupt nur immer noch benutzen. Ähm da gab es vor vielen Jahren schon so ein Bundespolizei, ich glaube zweitausendzehn. Das sind also kleine Dinger.
Damals fand ich, also sie sind heute vielleicht anders, aber das waren kleine Geräte, die.
Über GPS ihre Daten, ihre Position einfach regelmäßig ähm an den Server gefunkt haben.
Keine Abhörwanze, sondern so ein Geotrecker.
Ja warte, war noch nicht fertig, die Geotricker, genau, also Geotrecker, der ein einfaches AP Protokoll hatte, dem du sagen kannst, okay, ich will alle so und so viele Minuten einfach die Location geschickt haben, ne? Und dann halten die eine Datenverbindung und über die haben die halt bei einer AP ihre Daten.